ضربه كبرى جديده اطاحت باسعار العملات
الرقميه التي شهدت تراجعات قياسيه في
اسعارها منذ بدايه العام الجاري
هذه الضربه تمثلت في اعلان شركه باينس
التي تعد احد اكبر مواقع تداول العملات
الرقميه في العالم تخليها عن صفقتها
الكبيره المتمثله في شراء منصه اف تي اكس
للعملات المشفره
واوضحت بينز انها ستتخلى عن شراء تلك
البورصه الرقميه نتيجه لمخاوف تتعلق
بممارساتها التجاريه وبسبب التحقيقات التي
تجريها الولايات المتحده بشان اداء هذه
المنصه اضافه الى معانات هذه البورصه من
ازمه سيوله قياسيه
وكشفت صحيفه فينشل تايمز البريطانيه
صارت في حاجه ماسه الى ثمانيه مليارات
دولار وذلك لتعرضها لعمليات سحب اموال
قياسيه من عملائها اكثر من ذلك اعلنت لجنه
الاوراق الماليه والبورصات الامريكيه
توسيع نطاق تحقيق القانوني مع هذه المنصه
ويتضمن هذا التحقيق قضايا اقراض العمله
فراغ وسوء اداره اموال العملاء هذه الازمه
تسببت في خساره القيمه السوقيه للعمولات
المشفره اكثر من 200
مليار دولار خلال اقل من 30 ساعه هذا
الامر يعني تهاوي قيمه هذه العملات الى
880 مليارات دولار وذلك من مستوى من بلغ
تريليونان وخمسه وستين مليار دولار قبل
هذه الازمه اكثر من ذلك خسرت عمله بيتكوين
خلال 24 ساعه فقط اكثر من 12% من قيمتها
كما خسر تلك العمله المشفره 20% من قيمتها
خلال سبعه ايام كما نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن
مصادر مطلعه قولها ان مؤسس منصه اف تي اكس
سام بانك من فرايد قد يتقدم بطلب لاعلان
افلاسه اذا لم تحصل منصه على تمويل
وبحسب مؤشر البلومبرج للملياردورات انخفض
صافي ثروه فرايد من 15 مليارا و600 مليون
دولار يوم الاثنين الماضي الى 901 مليون
ونصف المليون دولار ياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي وسعت فيه العملات المشفره خسائرها
لتفقد نحو مئه و90 مليار دولار من قيمتها
السوقيه على مدى اسبوع كما تجاوزت خسائر
تلك العملات الرقميه منذ بدايه العام
الجاري اكثر من تريليون دولار